Firewatch Kevin Bernard yeah so first
let's talk what is it it's a game from
campo santo a new studio made up of
folks from Telltale irrational Bioware
and you can kind of see like if you look
at the games that those teams published
maybe there's some through lines but you
basically play as a dude who's in a
Firewatch station in the Wyoming
wilderness your job is to look out for
fires and in the demo you basically like
a you know a first-person you're walking
through forests you're going down to a
lake you're telling some folks to stop
shooting off fireworks please and thank
you and then you're sort of walking back
to your forest so from a gameplay
perspective it's basically a walk and
talk you left half a bottle of whiskey
decent stuff drunk pyromaniacs great
yeah um but the game is I mean that's
what the game is but I think what the
game is about primarily is about the
relationship that you're developing with
Delilah who is the woman on the radio
that guides you through all of this
process she's your boss yeah another
fertilizer totally and the you know
she's guiding you through and you get
the chance to respond to her this is
where the choice aspect comes in again
as you might expect from the walking
dead you know people that made walking
dead and bioshock and so on and so forth
you know that you know they want you to
make to make choices but the choices are
primarily going to be affecting the way
you and Delilah interact yeah and some
of the responses are a little more
sarcastic or a little cranky or a little
bit softer kind of kinder [ __ ] cool
it with the fireworks it's done Dominus
hopefully there won't be any more
trouble good thanks for going down there
so in a game that is so much about the
relationship and the dialogue between
two characters and this you know that's
fueled by this sort of exploration
gameplay what does it take to make that
more than just Oh some neat dialogue in
a pretty place what's gonna take to hook
you Kevin I think it's all going to come
down to the voice acting and to the
writing it's going to be about how in
did are you in Delilah and your own
character because if you're not invested
there's you know there's no point to any
of this you need to be invested in these
people in order to in order to keep
going and and I think the other thing is
going to be avoiding cliches I actually
talked to the developers at a long
length as it happens about all of the
you know all the the unforeseeable
problems it's become into when you have
this branching dialogue that focuses
mainly on two characters ah but I'm
interested because I feel like
eventually this story must come to a
point where you meet Delilah right and I
kind of offered them the ideas is it
sort of gonna be like online dating
where you've built up an idea about
somebody for so long but upon that final
meeting you know are you gonna be
delighted because there's so much like
what you imagined or depressed because
they're nothing like what you thought
there's some guy out here some guy wait
he's looking at you is he doing anything
else I I don't think so
there's something I something someone
should have told you about this area
what is it it's outside come on the
whole thing and people come and go as
they please it's it's it's madness yeah
yeah okay I get it there's a mystery
that starts to develop as you go on you
go back to your station the sort of your
look out and discover that it's been
ransacked yeah so and you have you seen
a figure serious mysterious figure so
there's more to it than just the
relationship of course but you know
you're looking at a game that's
primarily about story here it's like
puzzle solving and know how do i get my
native and so forth it's also worth
noting that it's it's quite lovely it's
quite lovely absolutely this demo was
set at sunset and you see i spent time
just panning across the the wilderness
kind of looking at it i was surprised to
look down and find my like big wreck it
ralph hands I don't know what I was
expecting character models to look like
but I yeah yeah I'm intrigued I can't
wait to play the full game it was an
interesting demo I wouldn't say that I
was quite blown away but I'm looking
forward to seeing what more the
developers do with this one me too oh I
can see my tower from far away yeah we
experimented with hidden underground
towers for a while but we're really
happy with the results I'm with you all
summer huh with whatever this sense of
humor is can you even believe you're
gonna love it